william ruto fue electo como nuevo
presidente de kenia tras la revelación
este lunes de los resultados de los
comicios más ajustados de la historia
democrática del país
declarada declaró solemnemente que ruth
o william samoei con número de identidad
68 47 208 ha sido elegido presidente de
la república de kenia
[Aplausos]
o las provisiones del artículo 1.8 de
las constituciones de construyó el
vencedor de la contienda presidencial
william ruto obtuvo el
54% de los votos brutos se presentó como
un hombre hecho a sí mismo y apeló a los
ciudadanos de a pie a confiarle el
fortalecimiento de la economía fue
vicepresidente del país desde 2013
durante la presidencia de uro keniata el
jefe de estado saliente que en estos
comicios dio su apoyo a su opositor
raila odinga percibido por lo tanto como
el candidato del oficialismo los
comicios se celebraron el martes 9 de
agosto pero los resultados se retrasaron
debido a las acusaciones cruzadas de
fraude electoral que persistieron antes
y después de conocerse el ganador
ingenieros campings en kenia cuando algo
tarda demasiado en suceder hay algo
sospechoso en el fondo esa es la
percepción que siempre tenemos algo que
tarda algo malo está sucediendo
las tensiones estallaron en peleas
minutos antes del anuncio oficial de la
ajustada victoria de william ruto cuando
el vicepresidente de la comisión y tres
comisionados calificaron el proceso de
opaco y rechazaron responsabilizarse del
resultado el país queda así a la espera
de una posible impugnación de los
resultados ante la justicia un episodio
que amenaza con desequilibrar el país
más estable del este de áfrica y el
principal motor económico de la región
[Aplausos]